[Music]
on this Thursday night mounting anger
and angst among Calgary parents the E
coli outbreak that severely sickened
some children lives are on the line here
the fears it could lead to long-term
health problems investigating foreign
interference finally a judge's name to
take on the public inquiry trapped deep
inside a cave I need a lot of help to
get out of here the mission to save an
ill man stranded a thousand meters
underground and mourning a journalism
Juggernaut remembering the Fearless
Peter C Newman
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us there
is growing Anger from parents of more
than 100 children in Calgary after an
outbreak of E coli at a number of
daycares Alberta Health Services says
there are now 128 lab confirmed cases of
the infection and 25 children are in
hospitals nine of them have a syndrome
which can cause kidney damage and that's
what doctors are most concerned about
Heather urich's West has our top story
tonight in a warning the symptoms some
of these children are suffering are
quite graphic
Sarah McDonald is exhausted and anxious
the past few days she's been focused on
her son's Health Lachlan spent like
nights on the toilet he couldn't even
sleep in his bed he was passing not just
blood but flesh in his stool her
four-year-old one of dozens of children
who became violently ill after
Contracting E coli at daycare he is now
suffering from a bowel prolapse as
doctors watch for signs via daily blood
tests of a potentially fatal blood and
kidney disease for the families of
children who are not actually admitted
in hospital one of the biggest
challenges they have right now is these
blood tests people are waiting six seven
hours in the emergency room every day
because the blood tests have to happen
every 24 hours hemolytic uremic syndrome
is a condition most often caused by E
coli it can cause anemia and impair
kidney function up to 20 percent of E
coli patients develop hus from the
family's point of view it's it's very
difficult disease because children can
be very well and then three or five days
later be significantly ill with with
decreased kidney function it's a Road
the link Rogers family has traveled down
before two-year-old Rhett developed each
us after an unrelated outbreak of E coli
in the fall of 2022 the child went into
renal failure and spent nearly two
months in hospital including four nights
in intensive care he has chronic kidney
disease and he has brain damage so we're
dealing with
um some developmental delays this
current outbreak first declared on
Monday involves several daycares and
schools that all shared the use of
essential kitchen operated by the
fueling Brain Academy though the source
of this outbreak has not yet been
officially confirmed according to
documents posted on the Alberta Health
Services website the fueling brains
Academy kitchen and one of the fueling
brains daycare locations had been found
in violation of Public Health
regulations related to food handling
before anxious parents say they want
answers and accountability as they watch
to see if their children become sicker
than they already are Heather York's
West Global News Calgary
the company behind the one chip
challenge is removing its spicy product
from store shelves after the chips were
blamed for the death of a teenager in
the United States pockey says the
challenge was intended for adults only
with clear and prominent labeling but it
admits it's seen an increase in teens
and other individuals not heeding These
Warnings the company says it's working
with retailers to remove the product a
14 year old boy near Boston died after
eating one of the chips which are dusted
with two of the hottest peppers in the
world his autopsy results are pending a
judge with the Quebec Court of Appeal
has agreed to had a public inquiry into
foreign interference in Canada Jose
Marie OG says she is honored to take on
the role of commissioner she became a
lawyer in 1987 mainly practicing
corporate commercial and civil
litigation and has appeared before all
levels in the Quebec civil court system
as well as the Supreme Court of Canada
and multiple National and international
tribunals she was appointed to Quebec's
court of appeal in 2015. last winter
Global News broke stories about attempts
by the Chinese Communist party to meddle
in Canada's Federal elections this
inquiry will investigate foreign
interference by China Russia and other
foreign State and non-state actors it's
not known when it will begin or how much
of it will be made public Toria isri
reports
the Trudeau government is trying to
counter China's influence with an
Outreach in Southeast Asia and a major
announcement back home good morning
everyone Public Safety Minister Dominic
LeBlanc named justice Marie Jose to lead
the inquiry she will be able to
undertake her important work with the
full support of all recognized parties
OG will look into how China Russia and
other foreign actors tried to meddle in
the 2019 and 2021 Federal elections she
must submit her initial report by
February 2024 and a final report before
the end of that year Oak was chosen
after months of searching and
negotiating with opposition parties who
want measures in place to protect
Canada's democracy but the Quebec judge
does not have National Security
experience there is value also in
finding a senior credible Justice who
comes to this issue issue with a with a
fresh set of eyes she takes over from
former Governor General David Johnston
and inherits a rule mired in partisan
fighting with respect to my connections
with the Trudeau Foundation Johnston
stepped down as special rapper tour in
June he ruled out calling a public
inquiry and faced accusations of a
conflict of interest over his ties to
the Trudeau family I'm really glad that
the public inquiry is now starting we've
wasted a lot of time last spring reports
emerged that ceases had detected a plot
by China to intimidate conservative MP
Michael Chong and his relatives in Hong
Kong
Ottawa expelled a Chinese Diplomat in
retaliation Beijing looms large over
Trudeau's Asian tour when asked if there
was any chance at a rap Roche small with
China Trudeau was unequivocalo
um certainly not at this particular
moment prime minister Justin Trudeau
visited Singapore Asia's Financial Hub
to shore up business
economic policy is also security policy
Donna teria Israel in Singapore tonight
thanks the federal conservative party is
spending the next few days hammering out
what its priorities are going to be
before the next election more than two
thousand members of the party are in
Quebec City and they are encouraged by
the latest opinion polls according to
Abacus data if an election were held
today 40 percent of those polled would
vote for the Tories it's their largest
lead over the liberal since the 2015
federal election David Aiken is at the
conservative policy convention
conservative MPS are in a good mood and
why shouldn't they be the party has had
a big lead over the Liberals in several
polls over the last few months its
fundraising machine is collecting more
money than all other parties combined
and they are united behind the leader
they think can bring them back to Power
ladies and gentlemen this is the common
sense of the Common People United for
our common home your home my home our
home let's bring it home
foreign
conservatives The Next Step voting on
policy priorities for the campaign
platform the Grassroots of the
conservative movement uh are as excited
and positive and United as they've ever
been particularly under uh Mr pauliev's
leadership delegates will consider about
60 policy proposals including giving
parliament's ethics commissioner more
power cutting all subsidies to any Media
Company including the CBC taking a
tougher stand against China simplifying
tax rules conservatives will also debate
proposals to ban minors from gender
affirming surgeries and care and to ban
minors and those dealing with mental
health illness from accessing medical
assistance in dying some of those
proposals might be voted down some might
pass but the final decision to put any
or none of those in a party platform
belongs to the leader and the leader's
power to do that will also be subject to
a vote this weekend what will be
important for Mr polyev and his team to
do and I believe they're doing this is
to make the case as to why change uh
including Pierre is the right choice for
Canadian families the next election
though was probably two years away with
the Tory so far ahead in the polls there
was really little incentive for the
Liberals in the NDP to break their deal
to keep Parliament going until 2025.
Donna all right David Aiken in Quebec
City thanks David political tensions
were at the Forefront of a federal
debate on Canada's record-breaking
Wildfire season the liberal government
went after their political opponents
claiming the Tories are taking a head in
the sand approach to climate change Eric
Sorensen reports on that and the toll
the fires have taken on the country this
year
more than 6 000 fires 284 evacuation
orders over 230 000 evacuees there's
never been a year of wildfires like it
in this country but experts believe we
will see more like it in the future
Canada's warming about twice as fast as
the globe and the Canadian Arctic about
three times as fast this kind of trend
we're seeing will be something that
we're going to see continually
increasing over the decades to come what
stands out is how widespread the fires
have been this year from Nova Scotia to
BC to almost the Arctic Coast Quebec has
had record fire activity this year more
than 5 million hectares burned followed
by the Northwest Territories Alberta and
BC and here's how different it has been
this summer since 2014 you can see the
progression of total area burned by year
it peaks in the early summer and levels
off around September at around or below
4 million hectares here's 2023 the area
Burns surpassed all other years by
mid-june and kept burning to more than
16 million hectares as of yesterday and
what is also now simmering in this
country is a political firefight over
what to do Trudeau's carbon tax new ads
by conservative leader Pierre poliev
take aim at the federal government's
carbon tax to combat climate change
enough I'll ask the tax so you pay less
and bring home more at a federal
briefing today one Minister after
another used the latest Wildfire data to
question how serious the conservative
leader is about climate change it is no
secret that since Mr palia became the
leader of the conservative party the
words climate change have barely passed
his lips we all know that Canadian
deserved leaders who aren't afraid to
face climate change in our country
Canadians may be torn by a wish to
combat climate change yet also bring
down gas prices but scientists suggest
you can't have it both ways I think
Canadians should recognize the reality
for their children and grandchildren
that we need to have a carbon tax reduce
emissions says McBain learn to adapt and
what may be the steepest challenge for
all levels of government to work
together to combat climate change the
2023 wildfires meantime could burn or
smolder in BC Northern Alberta and the
Northwest Territories to late fall or
winter Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
an American cave specialist is stranded
in one of the world's deepest caves
after he got sick during an expedition
Mark Dickey is more than 900 meters
below ground in a Turkish cave and he's
been there since Saturday when he
developed gastrointestinal bleeding
there have been cave rescues before but
none as deep and as complex as this one
Jennifer Johnson reports
Mark Dickey from nearly a thousand
meters 40-year-old American scientist
Mark Dickey on video stranded way below
the entrance to the vast maurja cave the
experienced cave Explorer fell ill last
weekend a support team including a
doctor went down giving him several
blood transfusions now he awaits his
rescue right now it's a day to two days
worth of travel for information to get
back and forth so I don't quite know
what's happened but I do know that the
quick response of the Turkish government
to get the medical supplies that I
needed in my opinion saved my life
Rescuers believe they can get Dicky out
but it will be very difficult the roots
of the cave has many small twists and
turns complicating the rescue especially
since a stretcher will likely be needed
there is no case in a world where we
have the the biggest cavesque operation
we have really technical demanding
rescue because even for caver it's some
sort of challenge to reach that that
Dickey was leading an expedition to find
and map a new passage in the cave after
his internal bleeding started he was
unable to eat and was semi-conscious for
three days as you can see on me up I'm
alert I'm talking but I'm not healed on
the inside yet so I need a lot of help
to get out of here experts say climbing
out of this cave for a healthy Elite
caver is the underground equivalent of
climbing Mount Everest the turkey caving
Federation is being joined by multiple
cave rescue teams from Europe and the
U.S setting up rope lines and rigging
different sections to create a safe path
out he's bored and starting to go
through his gear and repack and and fix
things and
um so he's getting ready for the trip
home experts say this operation could
take several days or even weeks
depending on conditions Dickey's parents
and friends are holding on to hope the
caver's condition remains stable as
Rescuers Race Against Time to free him
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
a former sitcom star sent to prison
coming up the punishment for actor and
convicted rapist Danny Masterson
Danny Masterson an actor best known for
the sitcom That 70s Show has been
sentenced to at least 30 years in prison
for the rapes of two women he will serve
two 15-year sentences consecutively and
must register as a sex offender If
released the women's lawyers said
despite persistent harassment
obstruction and intimidation these
courageous women helped hold a ruthless
sexual predator accountable today the
47-year-old was convicted in May of
raping two women at his Hollywood area
home in 2003 when he was at the height
of his career a mistrial was declared on
a third count involving Masterson's
ex-girlfriend
the head of one of the most powerful
talent agencies in Japan is stepping
down after an investigation confirmed
her uncle who founded the agency had
sexually abused hundreds of boys since
the 1970s Julia fujashima bowed as she
faced reporters acknowledging and
apologizing her uncle's abuses the
allegations against Johnny kiragawa came
to light after a tell-all documentary by
the BBC earlier this year several
victims came forward claiming he preyed
on young dancers and singers and an
independent investigation confirmed
hundreds of cases of abuse kiragawa died
in 2019 he was never charged
Bruce Springsteen is postponing all of
his September concerts of His World Tour
on the advice of his doctors
[Music]
says he's receiving treatment for peptic
ulcers a common and often painful
stomach condition he says he's
heartbroken about the postponement eight
shows are affected the 73 year old will
now have a two-month break before the
Canadian leg of his tour starts November
3rd in Vancouver
up in the air ahead the debate over how
to say about 300 year old landmark in
Quebec
foreign to the category of don't try
this at home a Florida man has been
arrested for trying to cross the
Atlantic Ocean in a human-powered
hamster wheel 44 year old Reza Bellucci
was discovered by the U.S Coast Guard
off the coast of Georgia attempting what
they call a manifestly unsafe Voyage
they say when confronted he threatened
to blow himself up it's not the first
time at this he's attempted the same
thing a couple of times before
a city on Montreal's West Island is
struggling to decide what to do with a
landmark at 310 year old windmill serves
as a symbol of that City but it's
falling apart as Mike Armstrong reports
while everyone agrees it should be saved
there's no agreement about how
it is basically everywhere Point
Claire's windmill is on its City Hall
it's water tower it's on signs as you
drive into town and as you drive around
town it's literally on every street sign
but there's a big difference between
point Claire's windmill logo and the
actual windmill the real one is well to
be blunt crumbling it's in terrible
shape and it is disintegrating as we
speak and we have to do something about
it it is an embarrassment
the windmill was built in 1709 by
missionaries in what was then New France
Farmers used it to ground grain into
flower and it was also a fort a
defensive position in case of attack
from the south this is one of the
earliest photos taken the year of
Confederation
1867. it's something that is a source of
of wealth and value not just for Point
Claire but for the entire Province the
land and the windmill are owned by the
Archdiocese of Montreal spokesperson
tells Global News they're committed to
finding a solution but admits the
process has been challenging
prove otherwise there was a deal with
the city to restore the windmill but
some counselors pulled their support
public access was not guaranteed which
is a line of the sand amongst other
things the deal would have had the city
put up close to a million dollars and
the province another million the mayor
says most issues can be solved it's that
price tag that's the biggest problem
some people think it's irresponsible to
put this amount of money towards the
windmill I don't think it is I think
it's the only way we're going to save
the windmill well this is kind of
everyone's best case scenario a windmill
about a half hour away was built right
around the same time and was restored
last year in fact it actually works and
can do demonstrations
fortunately the party's trying to fix
the problem in point Claire have been
going around and around for a couple of
decades the local Heritage Society has
already actually raised funds and bought
millstones it hopes to install someday
Mike Armstrong Global News Point Claire
Quebec
[Music]
he questioned The Establishment next the
life and work of Canada's Peter C Newman
[Music]
one of Canada's most prolific
journalists and authors has died Peter C
Newman passed away from complications
related to a stroke he had last year his
impact on Canadian discourse was felt
throughout his decades-long career and
today he's being remembered for his
dedication to shedding light on some of
this country's most complex individuals
Mike drolet looks back at his storied
career
Peter C Newman asked for very little
from his adopted country when he
immigrated to Canada in 1940 he wanted a
voice and an audience he got both in
Spades thanks to a career chronicling
Canada's power Brokers nobody was off
limits from Conrad black to Mike
ignaciev the liberal and conservative
parties and most famously Brian
mulrooney who was in the wedding party
of his third marriage he really thought
he was the greatest prime minister since
McDonald which is pretty tough because
you know McDonald founded the country so
he couldn't invest him on that the
former prime minister didn't dispute the
facts in the book but he wasn't happy
offering a joke that wasn't a joke at
the Press Gallery dinner Peter Newman
Canada allowed only a handful of Jewish
families into the country during the
second world war the Newmans got in but
they had to agree to be baptized
Catholic still a young Peter Newman
loved his adopted home never ever
take being Canadian for granted
those of us who are immigrants don't and
you shouldn't either because this
country has the Mandate of Heaven
ultimately it was that love of Canada
that pushed him to question The
Establishment in all those that held
power regardless of the consequences
there is a tendency in this country to
be uh unduly respectful of uh of our of
our betters as it were and I think that
uh what Newman did was that he allowed
people to take a chance Take A Part shot
not worry too much about lawsuits Peter
C Newman a giant of Canadian journalism
was 94.
is global national for this Thursday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight's here Canada is
the highest point in the Canadian
Rockies Mount Robson near Valmont BC
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching Nito Garcia will be here at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I will see you
again on Monday bye-bye
[Music]